- [Kelly] Oh, my gosh. I love your dress.
- Thank you.
- It's so beautiful. Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you as well.
I'm a big fan. I have to say,
you were great in the "White Lotus".
Were you freaking out?
'Cause it's been one of
the most successful things
to hit TV streaming in a long time.
- I was completely freaking out.
I remember calling my mom the
first time I saw Connie going,
"what do I say? What is
the English language?"
Like, I can't speak right now.
- Yeah. Oh my God. I loved
her in "Friday Night Lights"
and "Nashville."
Did you?
- That was what my mom and I binged.
- Oh my God. It was so good.
I loved her. Anyway, and
you just had a birthday,
so happy late birthday.
- [Sydney] Thank you.
- So how did you celebrate?
- I went home. I grew up in Idaho and
- [Kelly] Oh, that's beautiful.
- Yeah. I grew up on a lake and so,
we went slalom skiing
and I saw all my cousins
and it was really nice.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
Idaho is so beautiful.
I love it. It's right next to Montana.
It's yeah, it's gorgeous there.
Wait, what a slalom?
Were you on one ski?
- Yeah. So it's one ski,
like one foot is in front of the other.
- So you're like really athletic. Yup.
- I am
- Yup. Have you ever wakeboarded?
- I have actually. When I was 12,
I got in a wakeboarding accident.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- And I jumped the wake.
I tried to do a 360
and I hit the tip of my board
on the water and it caught
and my face sliced the board
and I had to get stitches.
- What? First of all, I love
that you attempted to do a 360.
Like, what?!?
- I had a dream of like
going to the X games
when I was little.
- Oh, my Gosh. Really? - Yeah